- Welcome back everyone
we're delighted to have
for the second paper in this mini workshop
Does Public Diplomacy Sway
Foreign Public Opinion?
Identifying the Effect
of High Level Visits
by Benjamin Goldsmith, Yusaku
Horiuchi and Kelly Matush.
So I believe Yusaku is taking the lead
on the presentation of this
paper, so please take it away.
- Okay, thank you very much
for giving us an opportunity
to present our papers.
So this is a paper which
then goes to me from ANU
and Kelly Matush from Florida State
and the title of this paper is
does public diplomacy sway
foreign public opinion.
So the many governments
invest significant resources
to communicate with foreign citizens
and this statement of government
sponsored communication
often called public diplomacy
represent a prominent component
of state's foreign policy today.
And the public diplomacy
activities include
government sponsored
educational exchange programs,
state broadcasting outlets,
and cultural events.
And these efforts are aimed
to shape global affairs through
improving the perception
of their leaders, country, people
and core values and increasing support
for specific policies.
To put it differently,
these different medical activities
are aimed to increase soft power resources
which we have been discussing
since the first paper.
So this the study of public
diplomacy has bloomed
into a substantial literature
but there's surprisingly
little well identified evidence
about the effectiveness
of public diplomacy.
Can government actually sway the opinion
of foreign citizens with
such diplomatic efforts?
So we argued that this
fundamental question
is essential to understand the impact
of strategic transnational communication
in modern international relations.
So to answer this question,
we emphasize the importance
of expanding the scope of
public diplomacy studies,
broad literature on
soft power, as you know
is US-centric in its
(indistinct) exposition.
And empirical study this
also tends to be based
on things that countries
most often the United States,
or at most fit.
This focus on single country studies
or maybe consult power does not allow us
to answer even basic ethical questions
about the general use of public diplomacy.
For example, questions about Japan, China
soft about competition, the
topic of the first paper
at this conference
or the impact of South Korean diplomacy.
Those topics cannot be
well addressed empirically
without a general
understanding of the efficacy
of public diplomacy across countries.
So to contribute to the literature
of public diplomacy and the soft power,
we focused on the major
and ubiquitous tool
of public diplomacy that is,
high-level political leaders'
visits to other countries.
So our study speaks to
several important issues
in international relations
beyond public diplomacy diplomacy.
So transnational communication
is seen as increasing
in relevance to international power
in the global information age,
and establishing that,
leaders can shape public opinion abroad
is a fundamental step to understanding how
and when States achieve
their foreign policy goals
in this context.
More broadly, public support
is relevant to a wide range
of international goals.
For example, existing studies
suggest that public opinion contributes
to a state's policy, states
policy on international trade,
foreign aid, military coalitions
and (indistinct) basis.
As a result, cultivating
for a public goodwill,
may assist a state in shaping
apart from our state's ability
to implement a design and a policy
across a wide range of policy regimes.
So leaders around the world,
devote significant amounts
of their limited time
to international travel.
According to the recent
study by Maurice and Semis,
recent US presidents spent
up to one side of their time
on international trips.
The primary reason leaders
travel internationally
is to have a closed door
negotiation with host leaders,
a host country leaders to discuss security
and economic issues or
other important issues.
But during high-level visit,
foreign leaders engage in
extensive public outreach
deliberately addressing foreign audiences
and attending public events
in front of TV cameras.
For example, visiting and a
host leaders may play charts.
They may have Sushi together
as a famous restaurant
or they may enjoy playing golf together
or the visiting leader maybe invited
to attend a Sumo tournament.
So why do they attend public
events in front of TV cameras.
Given the intense
constraints on their time,
the fact that visiting
often spend significant time
on public outreach while abroad
should suggest that they believe
this type of public diplomacy
brings substantial benefits.
We argue that they engage
in these public outreach
and image building activities
because a visiting
leaders wants to influence
foreign public opinion.
In other words, these events
outside the closed door meetings
are part of their public
diplomatic campaigns.
There are two ways visiting leaders
can sway foreign public opinion.
First, a visiting leader
try to increase awareness
of themselves and their country
among citizens in the host country.
Of many possible tools of public diplomacy
high-level visits are
particularly well suited
to gain the audience attention
due to the large amount of media
coverage they tend to draw.
Second, they try to convey
positive messages and images
often focused on the relationship
with the host country and its leader.
By sending these messages,
they attempt to increase the likelihood
that audience will be a view them
and by extension their country favorably.
But both pathways are
contingent on two things
First, how the opportunity, just a minute.
How the opportunity for
public diplomacy arranged.
Usually host leaders have
their own domestic incentives
to produce publicly visible
and a positive visit.
Produce publicly and a positive visit
which may show up their
own domestic support.
As invited guests of the
administration in power,
the visiting leaders typically enjoy
some level of endorsement
from their hosts,
increasing their legitimacy
in the eyes of the foreign public.
Therefore in most cases,
the host leaders' ability
to direct domestic attention
assists the visiting leaders,
leader in their public diplomacy goals.
Second, the second is how much one
and in what ways the media
cover for leaders visit.
Given the mainstream, I
mean nature of the visit
and incentives of both leaders,
the media coverage of high-level visits
tends to convey positive messages
and images about the visiting leader.
So if these conditions are not met
then a visit will not occur,
but to pretty differently
of a theory predicts
that when public diplomacy
visit actually occur,
it is likely that
incentives of the visiting
and host leaders are
reasonably well aligned
and the news media are likely
to produce some coverage
of the visit.
Therefore, a visit raises
awareness of the visiting leader
among citizens of the host country
and convey positive messages
about that leader to them.
So given this theory they
can expect the expectation
of a specific hypothesis
are the following.
High-level visits increase
favorable perception
of the visiting leader
in the host country.
They decrease indifferent perceptions
and they decrease unfavorable perceptions
but increasing by increasing awareness
we think that visit could
increase positive attitudes
by moving respondents from indifference
toward a positive opinion.
By conveying positive messages,
we also think that visit could
decrease negative attitudes.
Okay, to test this hypothesis,
we leverage natural
experiment to our situation
and estimate causal
effects of high-level visit
using individual level opinion posts
generated in the real world environment
at the time of high-level visits.
Specifically, we use, sorry.
We use one of the most
extensive cross national
and individual level data
available, Gallup World Polls.
And specifically to the
question when you use
for the analysis is, do you approve
or disapprove of the job
performance of the leadership
of the name of our country.
We combine this dataset
with our own original
data concerning high-level
by political leaders.
Identification strategies
for calls or inference is
to compare the respondents
to this question between
those who are interviewed
just before the first
day of a high-level visit
and those who are interviewed just after.
If there is no other systematic difference
between respondents
between these come through
and treatment groups, then we
can estimate the causal effect
by just simply taking
the difference of means.
So the combination of the two datasets
provides an opportunity to identify
the causal affects of visit by 15 leaders
from nine countries, over
11 years to 38 countries.
And we compared the approval
or disapproval of the visiting leader
among 32,456 respondents
interviewed either just before
or just after the first day of that visit.
So this table shows the
number of cases in our sample.
And before showing the of
a statistical analysis,
I like to focus on one specific case
to illustrate our research design
and some interesting findings.
So a case for this analysis
is Japanese prime minister
visits to South Korea
from November 1st to November 2nd in 2015.
So prime minister arrived in
Seoul on November 1st, 2015.
And within the five days before this date
81 Korean adults happened to
respond to their political
instead of respond to the Gallup poll
after the event, after the visit.
And among them 72.9% disapprove
of the job performance of it
and only 17.6% approved of it.
But within the five
days after his arrival,
101 Korean citizens
participated in this survey.
The importance is the percentage
of this approval dropped to 63.4%.
The difference is 9% apart.
On the other hand, the
percentage of approval
increased to 20.8%.
The percentage in difference opinions
also increased from 9.4 to 15.8.
So these changes are
consistent with our hypothesis.
And for this particular case
they changed the statistically significant
even for these 182 respondents.
What could explain these
changes in attitudes
among Korean people?
There are some factors
that could be consistent
with our findings.
The meeting between the leaders of Japan
and South Korea in 2015
was the first meeting in the three years.
There are many contentious
issues, particularly the issue
of about the so-called
comfort woman issue.
But the leader of the
two East Asian countries
agreed to improve their relationship
by continuing the dialogues
between two countries
and the prime minister of it (indistinct)
also smiled and shook their hands.
And these images were used in the media,
but there are also some other factors
that could be inconsistent
with our findings.
During the two day visits,
they only had one meeting and
no joint statement was made.
There was no also no press conference.
And typically visiting
leaders participate events
to meet the general public
or events to display their
friendly relationship.
But these events are not organized at all.
But there was an unexpected
event after the meeting.
So one of the debates during
the previous arrangement
between the two governments
was to whether to have lunch together
after the morning meeting on November 2nd.
So the Korean government tried
to set this lunch conditional
on the Japanese government's
pre visit agreement
to make a joint statement
which would set the target
date to find solutions
for the comfort woman issue.
But because others said
no to such a compromise,
president Park missed the chance
to set a friendly lunch
for public diplomacy.
And after the meeting
ended around 11:30 a.m.,
President Park asks a
prime minister of it.
So what is your plan after
this before your departure?
And other said, we'll
have a Korean barbecue.
And a guy went to a restaurant
not necessarily the very
special restaurant in Seoul
with people from the Japanese
embassy and other delegates.
And we actually also
know how much they paid
and they actually told
her how much they paid
was about $100 per person.
So it's not that expensive.
It's expensive for us
but maybe not so expensive
for the Japanese government.
And importantly this is the point,
the barbecue dance was widely covered
by the media in Korea.
Let me here criticize President Park
for not welcoming that guest
which is against the Korean culture.
While sympathy was directed
toward the prime minister of it.
By having Korean lunch, instead of,
for example going to a fancy
Japanese restaurant in Seoul,
at a local restaurant that
ordinary Korean citizen can go,
that perhaps succeeded in
mobilizing some favorable
at least not so hostile
attitude among Korean citizens.
So the example just explained
may have some other idiosyncratic reasons
why it affects the positive.
So we put all 86 cases like this example
and estimate the other age
effects of a high-level visit.
The statistical method is simple,
ordinary least squares regression
with a visit specific fixed
effects to see the variations
within each visit.
And we need to choose
the number of days before
and after the first day of the visit.
For the main analysis,
we choose five days,
but we also show in our paper
that affects our robust dislike
changes in this bandwidth.
The outcome variables,
the approval percentage.
Disapproval percentage
and a percentage of respondents
using neither approval
nor disapproval.
The treatment is simply
where the respondents were interviewed
before or after the
past day of each visit.
I wanted to show a substantial increase
in approval of the visiting leader.
This figure shows a
2.3% increasing approval
or average across all 86 visits.
A part from files will be printed
in 95% confidence interval
if they do not include zero,
the confidence is a
statistically significant
and highlighted in red.
The percentage of disapproval
decreases by 1.4%.
The percentage to
indifferences also decreases
but it's very insignificant.
The effect is substantially large.
For example, the hex
of approval percentage
is roughly equivalent to 40%,
41% of average annual change
of the approval percentage.
And in addition to being
substantively large,
these effects are not (indistinct)
So to estimate their duration,
we use a rolling average
based on a five day bandwidths
gradually moving farther
from the visit start.
So one to five, two to six, six to seven
and we compare this
with a fixed bandwidth control group
immediately prior to the visits.
So this figure shows these results
for the three, two response categories.
Again, statistically significant effects
are highlighted in red.
So most notably the increasing approval
for the visiting leader is endearing.
This effect appears to
last up to about 20 days
from the start of the visit.
The reduction in indifferent responses
also lasts for three days
and the reduction in subgroup
is relatively short lived.
So if indifferent views are
more likely to be weakly held
and based on low information
which is our theory,
then the greater duration
of the effects on these views
suggest that any lasting
impact of a high-level visit
operates more through
informing the uninformed
then through persuading
those who previously
held a negative view of the
visiting country or its leader.
Now, if our theory is correct,
a visit should influence public opinion
not only if the media cover them
and in other primary results,
we included all visit
regardless of whether we can
confirm any media coverage
of public diplomacy activities,
but to test the media coverage effect,
we divide all cases into
two with or without evidence
of public diplomacy
and then estimate that
(indistinct) effect separately.
And then this PD shows in
the right panel show that
in case of evidence or may be a coverage
of public diplomacy, there
is an increase in approval
and a significant decrease
in other responses.
But the left figure shows
that if there is no evidence
of public diplomacy,
just simply no effect.
So these results suggest
the cause or mechanisms
involving visiting a
visible public outreach
and a news media coverage.
These are commonly
assumed in the literature
help explain the effects of (indistinct)
So given the time constraint,
maybe I should skip the next two slides
but this figure is the
first of the two figures
showing our sensitivity checks.
So in order to fully understand
that these effects that
we estimate are effects
of public diplomacy.
In this figure, we tried to exclude
some cases of visit
like the visit with the
announcement of foreign aid,
the visit with certain kind of a set
or some other economic deals
because these deals are foreign aid
or even military aid may
change public opinion
but nothing to do with
the public diplomacy.
But after excluding these
cases, we see the same results.
And then this is another test.
It's also called a LIBOR one
out test, sensitivity tests.
So the literature may suggest
that the public diplomacy has some effects
if the visitors are the US leaders
but in order to see whether this is driven
by the effects of a particular country,
we excluded one country one and after
and then re-estimated effects
but the next (indistinct)
So meaning that there is
no single country driving
the average effect that we produce.
And we, I just presented.
So these findings support the core
and the largely untested assumption
behind most of the literature
on public diplomacy.
Public diplomacy actually sways
foreign public opinion, period.
And this is also the core assumption
behind young men that probably diplomacy
is an effective tool
to increase a country's
soft power resources, okay?
The effect that we find is
substantial, not so lift
and not specific to the US
and given the time constraint,
I decided not to introduce
some additional results
but in the paper, we
also present some results
of exploratory analysis
showing how much the
effects are conditional on,
for example the relations
between the host and the visitors
and the also the lens of office,
how long the visitor is in office
and some of the heterogeneous
treatment effects.
But if you have any questions about,
actually the paper is there.
So please, if you're interested
in those conditional effects,
please read our paper.
So we believe that other results
provide potential avenues
through which to better understand
how public opinion forms
on a range of important policy issues.
And the impact of foreign public opinion,
International Africa is closely tied
to the ability to influence that opinion
which we demonstrate in this article.
So we hope all the findings will energize
of a further investigation into the nature
of foreign public opinion formation
and its downstream effects on
policy outcomes, thank you.
- Great, thank you so
much Professor Horiuchi
for that presentation.
So now we have three discussions
starting with professor Christina Davis.
- Hey, thank you so much
for inviting me to
participate in this workshop.
Really two great papers
and a fantastic group.
I really enjoyed reading the paper
and it is even more rich than
this fantastic presentation
we've just listened to.
So while the paper cannot have
the lovely display of Korean barbecue,
it does have even more graphs
or query displaying a
fantastic set of results.
What I like about the paper is
it's really nicely connected
to the literature in soft power
while moving forward by focusing
in on a specific mechanism
not just public diplomacy,
but the leader visits.
And this is really quite interesting
because when we think of soft power
is sort of slow moving
components like coacher,
it's harder to analyze.
And so you both gain
better research design
and you gain better policy implications
by honing in on this aspect
of the leader visits.
And I really wanna
applaud them on that move
for both theory and
empirical research design.
And the findings are
really quite interesting
to show that there's, you know,
an increase in public
opinion, favorability
from a visit on the
magnitude at 2.3% points,
which they show is large relative
to the standard deviation
you might see in the movement
of how much you like Trump
or how much you like Xi,
and that's important.
It's also fascinating that the visits
are not rewarding the host.
In many ways, I've found that no finding
for the hosts getting a leadership
to be equally fascinating.
And so I think you might wanna
think more about why that is,
but it pays into their idea
that it's increasing attention
and appreciation where perhaps
there was less information.
And I guess the leader visit
showcasing your own leader
showing up with a Sumo match
doesn't add any new information about him
but that's very interesting.
I did want to know at a higher level
of thinking about soft power
is the ability to change
opinion about outcomes,
is the connection that
you like the leader more,
you like the country more
going to lead you to
have policy preferences
towards more cooperation.
And that might be the next paper.
This paper is already good.
I just wanna get four quick suggestions
of areas that could be improved.
I think that you could clarify first
what is the appropriate comparison?
Is your counterfactual
just that there's no visit,
to some extent I think
the richness of the paper
is trying to separate pump from policy
and the idea of just the visit
where you pose for pictures
and the camera as opposed to policy
and that in some ways that's disturbing
when you say that offering economic aid
or announcing an agreement
is not public diplomacy
where I would have
thought public diplomacy
is very much about delivering promises
of specific cooperation.
And so anyways I think
it'd be helpful to try
and think about that.
If you're looking at non visit,
or if you're thinking
about within the visit,
what share is it, how much you offer,
the agreements versus just showing up
and looking sociable and smiling.
And certainly you'd
want to look at the tone
of the agreements.
I mean, last week Smith visited Alaska
was not exactly a positive
meeting of all smiles
when we think about the
Chinese foreign minister
and Tony Blinken's engagement.
So you might wanna think more about
what are the tones of the agreement.
Second, how do their regime types differ?
So if you thinking about the meetings
you talk about how it shows shared values.
You might draw more on the
Trevor and sorority at all.
First paper, we've just been discussing
about how can a mismatch
of values make soft power
possibly even result in a backlash.
And so if you were to think about how does
an authoritarian democratic
diet have a different response
to public diplomacy than if
it were democratic democratic
and that might get at this, you know
are you telling us something
different reversing stereotypes
or because you're
different, you're coming in,
you're criticizing in which
case you might see backlash.
And so you might actually
have stronger effects
if you were to sort of parse out
these potential different effects.
Three, since we're all
interested in Japan,
I had to redo the appendixes
which are quite long and detailed.
And you go through all
of the sensitivity tests
to taking out countries.
And when you take out the
leader visits by Japan,
it attenuates the effect
size from 2.2 to 1.9.
Now, if I'm interpreting this correctly,
it means that actually Japan
gets a lot from its visits
and China was the other country
that appears to have
you know, taking China
out of your pooled results,
attenuates the average effect.
But maybe I read it too quickly there.
And then the last point
that's really interesting if
you're trying to go further
on some of the details, what is the visit?
Are you having different types
of heterogeneous treatment effects?
And you have the fly over meeting
versus the three-day we're gonna stop.
And you show that many of the
visits actually zero nights
meaning it was just a quick stopover
whereas others could be three days.
And I'm a little worried
when you're always measuring interviews
as after the first day,
sometimes the leader
has already made their
press release and left,
other times they're just in the midst
and the press is still
rolling on an ongoing visit.
And so I think you might
wanna separate that out
but those are the details.
I think overall it's
really a fantastic paper
and also name as much more qualified
to think about public
diplomacy and soft power.
So I should yield the authority.
- Great, thank you.
Thank you for seeing that.
Now we will move on to
soon to be professor,
Naima Green-Riley.
- Thanks so much.
Well, I will echo what Christina said
by saying that I've very much
enjoyed reading this piece.
I'd seen an earlier draft of this.
It was shorter
but this version really
goes deep on the question
of how foreign leader
visits affect public opinion
about the leader's job performance.
And I think that the paper makes a lot
of really important contributions, right?
Because there isn't
very much empirical work
on the effects of public
diplomacy right now,
the dataset and the way
that the authors manipulate
the timing of the interview
is innovative and creative.
And so I have a few comments,
I'm gonna divide them
into theoretical comments and
then some empirical comments.
First theoretical comments.
So you say in your hypothesis
section that the majority
of messages about a foreign
leader there in the media
during any visit will be positive.
And I think that that
particular point is a point
that gave me the most sort of angst
and the thing that I probably
disagreed with the most.
And it, the reason I disagreed
with that is I think that
I worked in some places
where we have hard relationships, right?
But China and Egypt, I know
that when we had leader visits,
we were always fighting the media.
Like don't publish that
because that's not true.
Don't lie about the leader.
Don't say things that
make the leader look bad.
And so that relationship between the media
and the public diplomats
is definitely not one,
always that's just one of joy
and more related to your paper.
I don't think
that the media coverage
will always be positive.
Definitely when practitioners
read this paper,
they would also disagree with
that point really strongly.
So to fix that, I think if you just said
that the news coverage of
the country and the leader
increases around the time of the visit
and didn't necessarily
make that statement that
and on the whole, the
coverage is gonna be positive.
At least we know that there'll
be sort of this increase
in attention towards the
country, probably should.
Secondly, you mentioned
the host country leader
has an ability to constrain
the public diplomacy success
of the visiting leader
in the theory section.
And you go into detail
about how there have been negotiations
between like the US and the Chinese
on how much public diplomacy
one of the leaders can do on a trip.
But then when I got to the empirical side,
I didn't necessarily see
any sort of discussion
about that type of a thing, right?
So the host leader
trying to constrain the
visiting leaders public posts,
they didn't really show
up in the empirics.
The paper is really rich.
I don't know my suggestion
is to add more empirics
that get to that point,
because I'm not sure if your
data lends it to doing that.
But I do think that by raising that issue
and then not talking about
it in the empirics part,
I had a bunch of questions
that then were unanswered
and probably could have been avoided,
maybe that part weren't in there
because it's not really a
part of your impacts anyway.
At the end of the paper
you make the point about the credibility
of the visiting leader as measured
through the amount of time that
the leader's been in office.
So really there's like a
section on the length of time.
It's flipped in that.
The section is about the length of time
the visiting leader has been in office
but then you make sort of
a statement than, oh, well
it could show that credibility matters.
And I'm not necessarily
sure that credibility stems
from how long a leader
has been in office, right?
So having been in office
could for many leaders
actually lead to a negative effect
of their credibility
depending on what they do
when they're in office.
So those are the theoretical
comments for empirics.
I wondered why in your robustness checks
when you add in covariates,
you only added in the
covariates of the variables
that were not balanced.
I recognize the empirical
reason for including
definitely the covariates
that aren't balanced
but even the covariates that
are balanced in the samples
would be interesting to have
in those regression results
just because we're still
learning about public diplomacy.
So any information we can have
about what different features
of people and respondents
matter to public diplomacy efforts good.
I would love to you see some information
on the baseline job assessment
or job performance assessment
of the 15 leaders around the world
in the host countries that you study
and then see evidence from you all
that the average job
performance of the leader
in the countries where you selected.
So there, I think 38 countries
that you did your analysis
as opposed to the job assessment
for those leaders sort of
globally is not different, right?
So what I really want to see is that
in the countries that you feel
like there's a lot of them
so there's a good chance
that this will work out fine,
but in those 38 countries
they're not more likely
to be liked already.
That makes sense on average.
And then last thing I'll
say I have more comments
but I'll send them to you
'cause I don't wanna spend too much time
is I'm curious about whether
there might be a bias
for democratic leaders in your data.
So I was just looking at the visits
that you include in the dataset.
And it seemed
like there might be more
trust by democratic leaders
in the dataset than trumps
by autocratic leaders.
And if so, I just that's, I
mean, that might be the case.
And if that's the case, I
think you should discuss that.
I think you should say, you know,
our data sets use if it does.
Here's a place where
that might matter also.
So in addition to the fact
that we just want to know
that fact, because it,
I mean that's your dataset
and we wanna understand
what the data set is.
There was a part of the analysis
where you look at places
where the visits were covered
by the media versus when they weren't.
And the coverage by the media
was measured through sort of
like this factor of a search
of English language sites.
You mentioned in your, in
a footnote that we know
that there are some problems
with not including local press
and only looking for English level news
or English language news
reports in the footnote
but I would assume that
you're writing that
because the visit could have been covered
by local press and you don't know
and so you're not including
the right countries
in your sub sample.
Another problem with that is
that if you're only looking
at English language new
sources, then I wonder
if your sub sample is now more likely
to be more favorably inclined
towards democratic leaders.
And if your entire set,
your entire dataset
of foreign leaders tends
to be more democratic
than it is autocratic, then
you got some bias there.
I'm gonna stop there, I'll
send you the rest via email.
- Great, thank you so much.
And then finally we have
professor Tetsuro Kobayashi.
- Thank you again.
So I'll keep it brief
'cause I already made some
comments on the first paper.
So the first, so I have
one methodological comment
and the other is perhaps more theoretical.
So for the first one I might have missed
in your presentation or in the paper
but I think there's some
sort of the indigeneity issue
because before high-level visit,
of course there's going to be
a lot of careful planning, right?
So Xi Jinping, you know,
has a plan to visit Japan.
And of course, to the US
but his visit to Japan
hasn't been realized
because, you know the
bilateral relationship
is not so friendly now.
So in other words, they,
you know, the host country
and visiting countries,
they both know carefully
planning and fairness
to make these kinds of,
you know positive impact
of visiting to be realized.
So, in other words, they, so,
the cases where there's
just some kind of backlash
or negative impact will be,
would have been censored already.
So in our is they're only cases.
So we can only observe the cases
where positive consequences
are reliably expected.
So if that is the case,
basically it is the outcome.
I mean, a positive impact on
public opinion is, you know
defining what cases are
going to be observed.
So I wonder how you could deal
with this potential indigeneity issue.
Relatedly, so you framed this visit
as kind of high rank officials visit
but my question, really, the
question how high it should be.
So Christina already mentioned
about the Alaska meeting.
So that's also the visit
of the Chinese hierarchal officials to US
but it was not, you know,
prison versus president meeting.
And then at the end
the result was really, you
know, not really friendly.
So does it have to be that country leader
like a president or prime minister
or can we, do we observe
have the similar effect
for those like at the
ministry level of visits?
The theoretical question
is about the mechanism behind this effect.
So overall I had an impression that
the most of the effect
is coming from kind of a
name recognition effect
because not many people
know about friend leaders
but when they visit their own countries
it's gonna be reported
and covered by media.
So that's basically where the
first time people realize,
oh this is a good guy and,
you know, good leader.
So I like him or I like her.
But there might be other
mankinds potential mechanism
for instance, in many visits,
the visitors bring some kind
of gifts or vineyards, right.
So, okay, we're going to
give you this foreign aid
or we're going to have this, you know
economic trade deal and so on.
So these are again
so carefully crafted in
advance of the visit.
And can we differentiate
defects of name recognition
from name, the fact of
more substantial 70 years?
If the name recognition is very strong,
I guess you can cast it
with your own very unique
interesting dataset because some, you know
people visited the same country
for multiple times, for
instance, from your table,
I get, I can see that Angela Merkel
visited Belgium for four times.
For instance, if name recognition effect
is the primary source of this effect,
then that impact would basically decrease,
in the second time, free time for them
because they all know
miracle already, right?
So you can, I don't know if
it's technically possible
but you may be able to capitalize
on this multiple visits
by the same visitor to the same country.
Okay, I think I should stop here.
So thank you very much for
this very interesting study.
I think so as other discussions,
I was so much impressed
because this is a really unique datasets
and combination of the
two sources of dataset
and the findings has a huge
implication, I guess, thank you.
- Great, thanks to the discussions.
We have already a great line
of people wanting to give comments.
So, I'll read out the list
and then I'll put it in the chat
so that people can just,
you know, follow the list.
It's Michael Tees, Amy
Catalinic, Phillip Putsy,
Mike Toms, Jennifer Linde,
and Takara (indistinct)
So starting with Michael.
- Okay, thanks.
That was a great paper
and a great presentation
you stuck with, thanks.
A couple of points.
First on Christina mentioned
that she was surprised
that there didn't seem to be
any sort of coattails effect
in terms of approval of the host leader.
And I'm wondering if that might not be.
And I guess part of the
reason that's surprising
is because why invite the visitor
if you're not gonna get
something out of it.
I wonder if there might be
countervailing effects there
sort of a possibility of a coattail
kind of basking in the glow of
the celebrity who's visiting
but also the possibility
that you sort of pair
by comparison in the
joint press conferences
or whatever other sorts of events
there are you sort of end up in the shadow
and you're diminished.
And so, and I wonder if there's a way
you could tease that out
in looking at these at these surveys
if there are questions that
might make give you priors
on sort of the relative respect
that the host leader and the visitor have
or something like that, to
kind of get a sense that maybe,
maybe there affects
working in both directions,
but the other question that
has more of a methological one,
and that's, I love this natural
experiment of did the visit.
I'm sorry, did this survey
response happened before
or after the visit started?
But I wonder if that's actually,
if it's actually unambiguous
that that's really the best cutoff point.
So, especially in so far as
media coverage is a big part
of the mechanism on some of these visits,
there's a lot of media
coverage on the run-up
to the visit about the
preparations, things like that.
And that may affect the responses
of people who are just
answering these questions
in the Gallup World survey
whenever they were answering them,
such that the maybe the
first day of the visit
is not the right cut off point.
And I wonder if you've moved
that around a little bit,
maybe something relative to
when the mentions of the visit
really started to ramp
up in the local media,
or something like that
as the question is sort
of when the respondent
and the survey was kind
of primed by the visit
as opposed to the actual events
of that visit at that point.
It might've, some of those
might even be anti-climax
at some point.
So just wondering if you'd
looked at that, thanks.
- Hi, so shall I just jump in?
Yeah, so thank you for this great paper
another stellar project
in this area from you.
I teach you other work.
So I was excited to read this one.
So I have two comments.
The first comment is that my colleagues
at NYU have published a paper
that you cite in your paper
about why leaders visit other countries.
And I know this paper well
and they sort of make this claim
that if a foreign leader
visits another country
it sends a signal that they expect
that the incumbent and the
other country will be in power
for the foreseeable future.
So a visit from a foreign leader
can help to prevent domestic
opponents and the host country
from attacking the incumbent
or criticizing the incumbent
and trying to depose the incumbent.
So this suggests
I was just thinking
about for your project.
It suggests that, you know, leader visits,
I mean you're not saying that
that random, but it suggests
that leader visits may
be more about the need
for fending off domestic opponents
or the incumbent may sort
of invite later visits
when they feel weakened or
they feel like, you know,
their hold on power is tenuous.
And I just wonder if it was worth thinking
about whether there's any
causal pathway potentially there
between the need for a visit
and on the part of the
host country and attitudes
in that host country
toward the sending country.
So that's my first point.
And in the second point
was just conceptually.
I was expecting the
question to be sort of more
about the favor ability of
the country or the favor,
sorry the attitudes toward the country
or favorability of the leader,
but instead it's do you approve
or disapprove of the job
performance of the foreign leader?
And that just like, that seems a little,
like people don't have views
often of the job performance
of their own leaders, let alone, you know,
the views of use of the job
performance of foreign leaders.
So I'm just wondering if
this is a situation where
you know, you never see,
so like the public in the United States
never see Stephen Harper doing his job
and then suddenly they see
Stephen Harper doing his job
by visiting their leader,
and like shaking hands.
And I'm just wondering
if this is more like
people don't have information,
so they are indifferent
and then they move
toward having information
which induces a positive attitude.
And your results same know
consistent with, you know,
there's evidence that it's indifference
moving to lessen difference
rather than people holding
kind of negative views.
But I just wanted to raise
those two points, but overall
it's a really great
paper and I enjoyed it.
And I really enjoyed seeing
that picture of Yakiniku.
Thank you.
I'm feeling quite
depressed right now, but.
- I think I'm next.
So I also enjoyed this paper a lot
and I think it's a really cool
approach to this question.
So two points.
So the first is about the
kind of substantive conclusion
and just think looking at
this from an IR perspective,
I didn't really buy the
idea that, you know,
this is sort of a
substantively important effect
which is not to subtract from the paper.
I think the paper is fine,
but kind of framing this
as a sort of an important, big effect,
I felt like didn't sit well with me.
So it's basically a 2% change
in the public opinion of a
foreign country for 20 days.
And so, you know, that
kind of magnitude of change
could matter if you're
running a domestic election
with a certain kind of electoral rule,
but it's the foreign citizenry, you know
and that marginal difference
is really not gonna have an impact
on any kind of policy
outcome that we care about.
And so to me, this, the punchline here
is it does have an effect
but it's not really gonna
matter for anything.
And I think that's still
fine in terms of the paper
because you're measuring something
and it might have other important effects,
but I didn't quite agree
with the way the paper
was framing the findings.
And the second one was
Christina's comment.
I think very similar
but the appendix K
coding of the the visits
they came with sort of a policy outcome
struck me as maybe being too strict.
Like, it seems like just subjectively look
thinking about these visits.
There's usually some press conference
where the leaders are saying, you know
this is what we talked about
and this is the progress that we made.
And so maybe, you know
the coding is a little bit
limiting in that sense.
Like there weren't any of
those that included Japan.
And it's hard for me to think of a visit
that doesn't come
with some kind of policy
announcement, right.
It raises questions,
like, why are they there?
You know, if there's
nothing of policy substance
that's coming out of the meeting.
And so I worried a little bit there.
And so it might be
worth talking, you know,
there are visits like that,
but it left me with some questions.
And so maybe that could
be addressed as well.
I have some more stuff
that I'll send separately.
A great paper, thank you.
- Great, Mike Thomas is next.
- Great, well, I thought this
was just a fascinating paper.
I learned a lot from reading it.
It was very thought provoking.
I have a bunch of comments,
but I'm gonna just give you
kind of two clusters of comments,
one about moderators and
one about treatments.
So my moderator's comment is an effort,
I think to connect the two
papers on today's panel
by suggesting that a key moderator
that's maybe not explored
in this paper so far
is the politicization of a diet.
So if the first paper on
today's panel is correct,
then efforts to increase soft power
including by diplomatic visits
should depend on whether
the dyadic relationship
between the countries
is politicized or not
one way that you could test that
would be by estimating
preexisting levels of hostility
and or favoritism between the countries
and or with the public opinion data.
You have looking at the
pre-visit popularity
of the foreign leader as a
measure of the moderator.
But let me deepen that point a little bit,
because I worry that your estimates
are probably an upper bound
on the positive effects of diplomacy.
You describe what you're doing
in the study as a natural experiment.
And I guess at some level
whether respondent
answers the survey before
or after the visit is as if random
but the thing that's not
random is the visit itself.
Guests have to be invited
and guests have to accept.
So let's suppose that
guests who aren't welcome,
won't be invited and let's
suppose that guests who think
that their visit might
not help or might backfire
probably won't accept the invitation.
Then those two things are going to limit
the general liability of your findings.
It's as if the subset of the visits
that we actually observe our best cases
for a positive effect of diplomacy.
So, anyway that's my attempt
to connect the two papers together.
My second comment is about
what counts as a treatment.
And I guess I have two
small things to say here
but one builds on something
that Michael already mentioned
because he was wondering
what counts as a treatment
the first day of the actual
visit or something else.
I have two suggestions there.
One would be to actually study the effects
of pre-visit publicity, if you can.
And the second would be to point out
that given the methods that you use
any pre-visit publicity effects
are gonna make it harder
for you to detect the
effect of an actual visit.
So to the extent that there's
bias in the estimates,
the bias is gonna be against
finding an effect on the day of the visit.
And so even if you can't study it,
you can at least sign the bias
caused by not being able to
consider those types of effects.
The other thing that I was puzzled to buy
and the treatments is that you find
it's based on the graph that
the peak impact of a visit
occurred around 15 or
16 days after the visit
and then declined very
sharply in the next five days.
So my question for you is what theory
of persistence and decay
could actually explain
that kind of pattern
if, for example, the effects persisted
because they learned something
about the foreign leader,
then why would they dissipate so sharply
within five days after
day 16, for example.
So I'm a little bit of thinking
about pretreatment effects
but also about the post-treatment effects
and how those could be
theoretically motivated
I think would help strengthen
what's already an
excellent paper, thank you.
- Great, thanks Jennifer Linda's next.
- Hi everyone.
So everybody's talking
about this paper is great.
This paper is so well-written
it's so clear, it was
just a real joy to read.
So seriously, congratulations
on really writing just a model paper
in terms of it was so easy to take in.
And, you know, one thing that
you might want feedback on
is the precision and the
models and the statistics.
I am definitely not that person.
I'm not gonna give you
soccer, statistical wise
but another thing to get feedback on,
you know I always ask
myself, what do we now know
about the world after reading this paper?
And so there, I can definitely
give you some advice.
I guess I had some of the
same reactions as as Phill
in terms of what have
we learned specifically
about things that the world cares about?
I think you have to bolster
that case in the piece.
Again, the thing that
the world cares about
is how a country can
persuade another country
to do something,
this notion of through attraction
or persuasion and so on.
And you associate that with, you know
I think quite sensibly, theoretically
with the concept of soft power.
So again, perhaps the
argument is a country
that has more soft power
will be able to negotiate
a more favorable trade agreement
or will be able to convince its ally
to take on more burden
sharing responsibilities,
for example.
But again, in the paper, that thing,
there's no evidence of that.
There's no evidence
that the leaders public
diplomacy affected this outcome
which is ultimately the
outcome that we care about.
So I think you need to bolster that case
to address the Phil's and
the Jenny's who were in the,
you know, your readership.
So I think the place, well,
one place that you can do this
is in the intro, like on page three,
you talk about public
diplomacy may assist a state
in shaping the partner
state's ability to implement
the desired policy across a
wide range of policy realms.
So this notion that it helps
the the other countries government
build the case for being more
helpful to the other state
and so on.
So I think that's really
promising, but again
that's a pretty weak statement.
Oh, it might do that, right?
So you gotta show us some
evidence that it does that
or also on that page, the
paper sites, different articles
talking about how public opinion
contributes to a state's
policy on a variety of issues.
And then there are a bunch of citations.
I think that's where you can
really fortify your case.
I think you really need
to build up the case
to people who aren't
familiar with those papers
and what they found and what
they argued in, what contexts
because that's the key
finding that people care about
that makes this paper really interesting
which is if that leader visits
and gets that resulting favorable opinion,
that's gonna lead to a better outcome,
a better policy outcome
for that leader's country.
And then let me just
quickly raise two issues,
by the way I'm gonna
send you guys comments,
written comments
so you don't have to like
write down everything.
Two issues that I thought were
really interesting takeaways
from this paper that they're currently not
kind of front and center,
I thought they were really interesting.
The role of the media
as you did talk about.
The role of, the media is like a filter,
plays a really important role here.
It's the way that people
learn about the visit.
And presumably there's
a narrative that's told.
One thing, one question
I had was how do you,
you have the figure in
the presentation about
to the extent that there
was media coverage, you know
what are the effects?
I was wondering how you
operationalize media coverage,
this in general, this made me think about
in settings where the
media are state controlled.
Does that mean that
if a leader visits a country
with state controlled media
then that is going to make
it better or worse or so on,
as it is public diplomacy
is still going to help
in those settings.
And I think that's a
particularly interesting question
to ask in this day and age
where we're looking at a rivalry
between an authoritarian
country and democratic one.
And then a second point, again
something that I thought
was really interesting
from your paper that I
would be interested in.
You guys exploring maybe
in a different paper.
As Christina said, I was really interested
in the fact that this was not
helpful for the host leader.
Why not write that up?
I actually think a lot of us
have the sense to say, you
know, stuff we come upon
when we're doing our
random reading for papers,
we learn about like, was it
like Helmut Kohl was up for an election.
And so he wanted Reagan to visit
that's when the whole like
Bitburg cemetery thing happened,
or but I remember like reading
like Helmut Kohl really thought
this was gonna be helpful
for him to have Reagan visit.
It's really interesting
if you guys find no evidence for that.
So again, that strikes me as
being quite a different paper.
I'm not even sure it's, IR
it's kind of is, but who cares?
But anyway, I think that leaders do think
that this is helpful for them
that it makes them look
statesman like, or whatever.
And, you know, at the very least
if you don't write a paper on it,
I think it would make a really
cool oped to be deployed
in appropriate time, thanks.
- I think Takara is next.
- Hi, so my point was similar to well
in essentially the same as Mike Tom's
but it's this idea of selecting
on the dependent variable.
So I was looking at page 16
on the paper where you say, you know,
because of the timing of the
poll GWP sampling timing is
not something that the
government will have taken
into account strategically
that it's as if random,
I just wanted to clarify
that I think that that is true,
but if we think of the
distribution of timing
before we say you have sampled
relatively randomly here,
I think that distribution might
be skewed on various things
like expectations of hosts
and recipient, or sorry
hosts and visitor teams
of this being successful,
the host and that could entail
things like media freedom.
So if the host country
can control the narrative,
it's a lot more, it's a safer visit.
It could be things like, so, yeah
Mike suggested politicization
level originally,
I guess, sorry, hostility level.
This kind of comes back to our paper too
because it's about how politicized
things are to begin with.
But I think one, you can
do these like kind of
like pseudo balanced
tests, but it would also,
I think even if you can't,
you know, stake balance,
you know, say that these
things are balanced
with these various measured,
just looking at randomly
sampling some of the cases
and seeing how these visits
are actually planned.
Like, to me it's a warning sign
that it's very choreographed.
No one would go
if it's going to be a
true disaster situation.
So actually seeing like,
if there's some sort of
risk associated with going
and so on would make the
case I think convincing
in terms of the overall
distribution before you sample.
- Great, thanks.
So I wanna take this time to
read two quick Q&A questions
from the audience.
I'll kind of briefly give my two cents.
And Michael, is your hand still raised?
Did you have another
comment, Michael Tees?
- Oh, no, sorry (indistinct)
- No, okay, oh, (indistinct) also, okay.
Let me, I'll read these two comments,
get my two cents and
then we'll go to help.
So from Shoko Watanabi in the audience.
Hi, my name's Shoko
I think the most important,
one of the most important
is that public diplomacy
is whether the prime
minister speaks good English
or other languages for example,
prime minister Abe used
to study (indistinct)
in his English and
pronunciation wasn't good.
If future prime ministers
can speak English well,
I think their approval
might increase more.
Another attendee noted that
they wanted to know more
about future developments in this research
and what areas will come into focus.
I'll just briefly say, you know
so I really enjoyed reading this paper.
It's fantastic, very well-written paper
and really interesting findings.
And most of what I was going to say
I think has been said
already, I'll just put a slate
maybe a slightly different
gloss on it, which is, you know
first this question, like
what seems like the core
to understanding the paper
is what's the big theoretical takeaway.
And I just wanted to
know more, I guess about,
the paper has a little
bit of the flavor of this,
of the reason the leaders are doing this
in order to increase
foreign public opinion.
But as I mean, and it elsewhere
you're careful to note of course
that there are other
objectives for these leaders,
but you know, as I think
Jenny and Phillip pointing out
it's not clear if it's exactly
rational for leaders to go
and participate in these meetings.
If what they're getting
is, you know, this 2% bump
which is big as it, as you
point out it's big and important
in the context of public opinion swings
but understanding that
kind of payoffs for it are
for the leaders and what
they're trying to be interesting
I guess the way that I had thought
about reading this paper
was there's this really
interesting bump in public opinion
that's probably not the primary
objective of these leaders
when they're making these visits.
And the other thing I just noticed,
you know this question is I think that,
you know starting with
Naima raises question
about like what's happening in
the local media environments.
And just even just some
more qualitative detail
on that in the paper that
explained what's happening
especially before the
visits and after the visits
in terms of media coverage.
And for me would help answer that
but I really would have fantastic paper,
really enjoyed reading it.
Ateho.
- Thank you.
I also wanna thank for the three authors
to provide a very interesting paper.
I just want to suggest you think
about three kinds of
different state fidgets.
One is a meeting between enemies.
In this case, you try to
send someone or invite
to make sure to agree to disagree.
In that case, a public
diplomacy will not be easy.
The second meeting is a state visit
between Alliance or very close friends.
This meeting is planned
already based upon a
successful relationship.
President Obama's visit
or inviting President
William Barg in 2011.
Trump's visit or
invitation to Abe in 2017.
So already a public
diplomacy is working well
and a state visit will maximize
its expected public diplomacy.
Final one is a tricky one.
Send someone or invite
someone to make your opponents
on your side or to drive
a wedge your visitor
and the visitors Alliance.
Xi Jinping's relationship
with the current South Korean
president to drive a wedge
between Korea and Japan.
So future expected
meeting between Xi Jinping
and a Japanese leader
during summer Olympic game
or future Xi Jinping
and the Biden's meeting.
This one will be very
difficult because already
there is very small room
for public diplomacy.
So I suggest you think about
the three different meetings, thank you.
- Great, thanks.
Does anybody from the paper
want to respond to any
of the comments so far?
- Hey, please.
- Yeah, I mean, overwhelming,
is that a really, really
awesome comments and questions?
And of course, I really
appreciate all this.
I think it's really exciting
to think about what, you know
where we can go next with
this project in the paper.
One thing that I'd love to talk about more
is how we're interpreting these results.
I think that we are not meaning to say
that any leader could go to any public
and expect a positive effects, right?
And we're talking about the incentives
of the media and the host
leader and those conditions.
I think we're precisely talking about
some of the selection
effects that you guys
are concerned about, right.
So I don't think that we need to say that
because we find it in
the sample that we have,
we think that this should apply
to any potential visit, right?
Would you say that's right,
but I take your point very seriously
about how we should consider
this a highest summit
and how we should think
about the distribution
of cases that we do have
and how that might apply.
I don't even know where to start.
Thank you very much for
all of these feedback.
- Yeah, I'll just also say
quickly, thank you very much.
This is really, really useful
and important feedback for us
and the points about the
broader theoretical connections.
The (indistinct) our literature
is something we tried to emphasize,
but clearly it's not
coming through well enough.
So that's something that
I think we can revisit.
We do, I mean, with the issue
of the indigeneity question
and the planning of the visits,
I did just want to maybe push back
or ask for a bit more
comment on that point.
I mean, yes, you know,
the visits are planned
and we acknowledged that in
there maybe consideration
of how it will be received
among the visiting, the
public and the host country.
But the, I mean, if
there is an indulginate,
an indulginative effect, there, it's,
it is not exactly our treatment
effect in the sense that
we may think the public
would be more receptive
to the visit or the, you know
the planners of the visit
may think the public
would be more receptive,
but you know, if the planning is well,
we think relations are going well.
And so opinion is already high,
or is already focused
on a particular country
that doesn't necessarily relate
to the before and after treatment effect.
I mean, it might be that if
a country is off the radar
or if there are negative
views about a country,
a visit would have a greater effect
than it would in an environment
where it's, you know
where the planning has gone through
and the case has been chosen,
or the visits been chosen
because relations are
already relatively good.
- I just wanna say, thank you everyone
for of these comments
and because I was presenting,
I couldn't see the comments there
but I look forward to reading all of these
after this event, yeah.
- Great, well, I think
with that, we've, you know,
on the US side, we're heading
deeper into the night.
I know that some of you are also in Europe
or authorities in the
middle of the nights.
Of course, if you're an
agent you're just beginning
what I hope is a good and fruitful day.
So I just wanna thank all of you
for a really fantastic lively discussion
of these two papers.
I want to thank Yusaku, Amy and Ben
for a really exciting paper
and especially the
discussions, Christina Davis,
Naima Green-Riley, Tetsuro Kobayashi,
Garia Rap Nicova, Joni.
And it's late enough
now that I'm forgetting
our third discussing professor Tago.
Sorry, professor Tago.
But thank all of you.
Thanks all of you for this
great lively discussion.
Hope to see you all again
hopefully in person in the near future.
Thanks everybody.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much everyone.